hi i am karen drexler i'm your neighbor
she doesn't like black people
well i'm black she doesn't like you
either
karen this
uh doesn't look great there's a new
movie coming out
it looks really bad i don't want to
judge a movie by its trailer because i
haven't obviously seen the movie yet
and the movie well take a listen
i'll take i don't want to color your
view take
is that a politically incorrect term am
i allowed to use that word anymore take
a listen
to the movie karen
tell me about your new neighbors they're
black that's mine keeping it down
if you don't comply i'll tell the
manager
somebody's taking home security serious
hi i am karen drexler i'm your neighbor
you need to be taking your trash cans
off the curb right when the trash is
picked up
is she nice yeah she's nice wait a
minute we have a
white entitled neighbor named karen
karen okay enjoy yourself there she is
slaving away in the kitchen
i've come across some very suspecting
teenagers can you please hurry up
please it's very aggressive yep i left
my wallet
with my id at home leave us alone we
didn't do anything
how the heck did you end up moving to
this neighborhood
next thing you know we have criminals
you take care of him
and i will take care of her would you
mind stepping out of the car
my office has uncovered some disturbing
information on
her and her brother she doesn't like
black people
we have a search warrant well i'm black
i know she doesn't like you either
karen ah this
uh doesn't look great people are
comparing this movie to get out
the difference of course is get out is a
good movie and this movie
is does not look very good right get out
is actually about this issue
of assimilation and this fear that when
you assimilate into a culture you lose
your soul
which is an interesting concept and i
thought it was a clever movie
this doesn't look like that this movie
uses a racial slur
which is karen some people are laughing
at the idea that karen is a racial slur
it is a rape i mean it's explicitly just
a derogatory term for white women
so i'm not i mean i'm using the term i'm
i've i've used some slurs i've used
just the other day actually in my book i
use a slur for italian americans
not not because i'm yelling it but just
in the context of describing it
i use one for the irish i use one for
asia i use a few i use them to point out
what these slurs are karen is a racial
slur
there's no getting around it it's one
that it's a mainstream one it's one that
we're all you're not really allowed to
say the other slurs and there's one slur
obviously you can you can never say
they would never make a movie with that
name but
the argument here is just preposterous i
think the reason
that get out rang true to people is
because
it's a legitimate fear it is not just
black people into a broader white
culture
but any group of people into any broader
culture there is a legitimate fear
of assimilation here the claim being
made
is that white women are committing
racist hate crimes against black people
that that's the defining epidemic of our
country and it's just
not true it just isn't happening we
talked about this
a few weeks ago on the show when you
look at the federal government's hate
crime statistics
you can look at the racial breakdown of
the offenders
and of the general population
52.5 percent of
hate crime perpetrators are
white and that includes hispanics
because hispanics have now been defined
as white
so just very slightly over half of the
offenders in hate crimes are white
73 of americans broadly including
hispanics who are now defined as white
are white so relative to their
percentage of the population
whites and hispanics are very very
unlikely
significantly less likely to be
committing these hate crimes
if you look at the percentage of hate
crimes committed by black people
that percentage is 23.9
if you look at the percentage of the
population total that is black it's 13.4
percent
so i'm not making any claim that it's
because of an intrinsic biological
reason or something that
whites and hispanics are relatively less
likely to commit hate crimes and black
people are relatively more likely to
commit hate crimes i'm just
i'm just telling you what the federal
statistics are i'm not saying we should
make
a movie with some black racial slur
about the way that hate crimes are
really perpetrated in this country
i'm not even saying that the term hate
crime should be a common term i think
it's a ridiculous term
because i don't think there are very
many love crimes
i guess that would be the opposite of a
hate crime i'm just pointing out
the reason that the trailer for karen
is risible the reason that we're all
making fun of it is because
while the ruling elites and the liberal
establishment tell us that the great
problem is white supremacy or
you know lebron james is telling us
black men can't leave their homes
without being hunted down by racist
whites we just all know it's not
true it's the furthest thing from the
truth when merrick garland the attorney
general comes out and says
the greatest threat to to us in america
the terroristic threat is white
supremacy we just know
that's ridiculous it's just absolutely
absolutely preposterous it is not true
and if you want to
solve problems of racial division if you
want to solve problems of crime which is
spiking in cities around the country
you need to be able to diagnose what is
really going on right
the first step to solving a problem is
admitting that you have a problem
and our culture will not do that i think
this is actually part and parcel
of this this broader alienation of
common
sense americans of all races of all
stripes of all appearances
from the group of of
silly mediocrities that that are
pretending to be the ruling class
hands up don't nuke that is the subject
of the entire show i'm glad you like
that clip you can watch the entire show
here on youtube
it's titled hands up don't nuke you can
also get it at apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play spotify myspace
xanga
live journal you can also get my book it
is out
as of two days ago speechless
controlling words controlling minds get
it wherever you get your books
subscribe smash the like button we'll
see you next time
you